[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is National Master Ralph tan and
welcome to beginner's breakdown today
we're going to dive into the concept of
space in chess so first things first
what is space so space in chess is
basically the control of squares so if
one has very little control over a
certain amount of squares they are
considered passive if one has lots of
controls over squares then they have
this space advantage in other words they
are active and they have many
opportunities that they can work around
with that space so what we're going to
do today is we'll look we'll take a look
at some games where a demonstration of
good space control is applied and also
some games where it kind of backfires so
we want to understand how we can extend
space and not to
overextend when obtaining space so if we
overextend by getting space then we
could
unfortunately have some weaknesses and
collapse so the first game that we're
going to take a look at is between cyber
Tash versus musinov in 1881 in Berlin
Germany so a little bit about these
players seber t was a German chess
master and a medical doctor by
profession he's considered to be one of
the best strongest players and most
influential theci of the late 19th and
earliest 20th century so tar is also
known for his defenses in the Queen's
Gambit Decline and his lines in the
French so for his Queen's Gambit decline
it would be D4 D5 C4 E6 Knight KN C3 and
C5 this is the tar defense in the
Queen's Gambit decline he also has a
line in the French where it goes E4 E6
D4 D5 Knight D2 the tarush variation and
essentially the idea of this is to
prevent any ideas of the Winward
variation where black would Place their
Bishop on B4 and try to pin the White
Knight and other player unfortunately
there is not much known about him so
let's take a look at this game so tarus
Begins the game with the move Pawn to E4
and now we have the move Pawn to C5 so
we have the Sicilians defense so the
game continues with the move Knight to
F3 and we have a little bit of an
offbeat opening a
very unconventional way to to play and
that move is Knight to H6 now Knight to
H6 is not really a good move because it
breaks opening principles so typically
when you want to develop pieces you want
to develop them towards the center the
four squares right in the middle as that
that's where all the activity all the
action is happening and the Knight is on
the rim so it's dim so it doesn't have
any real good squares to go to besides
G4 and and back home at G8 and typically
when you see the Sicilian most players
would play Knight C6 D6 E6 or Knight F6
so typical responses but in this game we
see Knight to H6 being played so with
Knight to H6 white plays to move Pawn to
D4 so essentially striking towards the
center and gaining a lot of space and
now we have the move Pawn on to E6
played by black so essentially what
black is trying to say is that if you
capture my Pawn on C5 I will take my
Bishop on f8 and capture the pawn on C5
back now what tarus is here is play to
move Pawn to D5 so essentially gaining
or further expanding his space so when
it comes to Sicilian whenever white
plays D4 there's a golden rule where you
should always capture the pawn on D4 as
the whole idea with the Sicilian Defense
is to trade the flank Pawn for one of
what of White's Center pawns so for
example probably Pawn takes D4 Knight
takes D4 A6 Knight C3 and Knight T6
would have been a little bit of a better
continuation so to punish this after E6
Tes goes for the move Pawn to D5 simply
rejecting the tension between the C5
pawn and extending towards the
center so now black could capture on D5
but white could just simply capture back
and have a very strong D5 Pawn so black
continues with the move Pawn to D6 so
opening up some space for his pieces to
go maybe his Bishop his Knight and
essentially just creating a strong
formation within his pawns now we have
to move Pawn to C4 now the idea would C4
is just to pretty much solidify on this
D5 Pawn so if the black pawn ever
captures on D5 then white has the choice
to either take it back with the c Pawn
or with the E Pawn so essentially being
really really solid here so now black
decides to close up the position and
kind of release the tension and plays to
move Pawn to E5 so all these pawns are
looking at each other and no no progress
can be
done now white plays a move Bishop to D3
just developing and next move ready to
Castle now we have the move Knight to G4
so once again breaking opening
principles so moving the same piece
twice uh twice more than twice so maybe
the idea for black is to kind of reroute
to F6 kind of finally finally realizing
that it's a much better squared in H6
and also maybe to avoid where white
could capture on A6 and maybe ruin
Black's Pawn structure so Knight 2 G4 is
played now white just continues and just
plays Knight to C3 so further developing
and going towards our Center squares now
we have the move Knight A6 so our
opponent as black really likes to put
their Knights on the rim but this time
Knight A6 is a pretty good move as you
have ideas to maybe maneuver to C7 and
there's no threats of this Knight being
captured by the Light Square Bishop as
there is a Pawn on C4 and the
away so we continue with the move Pawn
to A3
so the idea with this is to Simply
prevent this knight from coming to B4
and maybe trying to attack our strong
Bishop on D4 so now black continues with
Bishop to E7 so just continue
development maybe they're ready to
Castle next
move now we have castling for white so
prioritizing King safety as the king is
the most important piece and now we have
the move Pawn to
H6 so that idea with Pawn to H6 is maybe
to start some sort of initiative gain
space on the king side as we're really
lacking space within the center and the
queen side so maybe there's ideas where
G5 maybe you want to bring your pieces
over and start attacking where the white
king is located at so now white just
plays the move Pawn to H3 simply kicking
out this Knight on G4 so the Knight
Returns to its only safe Square F6 and
now white plays to move Knight to H2 so
now there's a couple ideas what white
can do here so maybe they want to try to
REM maneuver their Knight to G4 a much
better Square maybe offer some trades
and in addition with this Knight to H2
we have plans to extend our space and by
that it's this move Pawn to F4 so we're
ready to gain a lot of space and try to
attack the center and push towards the
king side so black plays the move Pawn
to G5 essentially stopping white from
further advancing to F4 as there is two
attackers on that
square so white now continues with the
move Pawn to B4 so now the pawn to B4 is
a little bit of a sacrifice here so
essenti what white is trying to say is
that if you capture my Pawn I will
happily capture back I'm extending a lot
of space on the queen side and this Pawn
on B4 cannot be captured because if
Knight takes B4 white has a nice tactic
with Queen to A4 check attacking the
king and also attacking this unprotected
Knight on B4 at the same time so we have
a fork so whatever black does here so
for example Bishop D7 will pick up the
Knight if they try to block the check
with their Knight trying to save both
pieces at the same time unfortunately
with this Pawn on D5 we can capture on
C6 so that pawn is poisoned so after B4
black decides to play the move Bishop to
D7 and now white just plays Pawn to B5
so further extending gaining a lot of
space and as we can see here white has a
lot of options for their pieces to go to
due to the fact that they have a lot of
space and black here is having a bit of
a hard time they're really passive not
many squares to go to specifically with
the bishop pair they don't really have
any squares to go to the dark Square
Bishop can only go back to f8 and there
are unfortunately no safe squares for
this light Square Bishop besides
C8 so after Pawn to B5 we have to move
Knight to C7 so simply getting out the
way of danger from this B5 pawn and
white just continues with Bishop to D2
so just following opening principles and
developing now we have Bishop to f8
played by black so black is kind of
changing their mind a little bit so they
don't like the fact that their Bishop
was on E7 kind of occupying the square
for maybe the queen and with that Bishop
on E7 it didn't really have too much of
a job besides protecting the D6 pawn and
Knight F6 but then again there aren't
really any dangers towards that so now
black is thinking of ideas of maybe just
placing their Bishop on G7 kind of
finging it and getting ready to Castle
so having a much more solid Fortress for
the king so white just continues by
playing A4 so gaining a lot of space we
have a lot of space in the center now we
want to try to gain more space on the
queen side so now we have Bishop to G7
sop and sheding ready to Castle next
move now white plays the move Pawn to A5
so white is slowly but steadily taking
their time gaining a lot of space and
kind of restricting black from having
any play here so we have the move
castling by black so essentially getting
to King to safety and now we have the
move Knight to E2 played by white so now
the idea with Knight to E2 is
essentially we're maneuvering we're
finding a better Outpost for our Knight
so our Knight on C3 was doing a good job
on the queen side having some support
alongside these pawns but white believes
that they can make their Knight even
better so what white really has in mind
are these squares F5 and H5 so maybe we
can try to infiltrate Black's position
by playing Knight G3 hopping into F5 or
maybe proposing a knight trade by going
to
H5 so now we have the move Knight to H7
played by BL so the idea with Knight to
H7 is maybe maneuvering ideas or maybe
Black's chance to finally gain some
space so some ideas like Pawn to F5
really trying to Counterattack the
center and get an initiative on the
white king since white is playing on the
queen side uh black is play trying to
play on the king
side and maneuvering ideas where maybe
black could play Rook E8 Knight f8 and
maybe Knight G6 kind of copying white of
trying to have the same idea of
infiltrating to F4 or the H4 squares so
we still continue with the move Knight
to G3 excellent move as we are
essentially preventing black from
playing Pawn to F5 as we have 1 2 3
three Defenders on that square while
black would only have one two their
bishop and their Rook so black kind of
lays back a little bit and plays a move
Pawn to F6 so black doesn't really have
much of a plan what they're trying to do
is just be really really solid as they
have this nice Fortress of Pawns kind of
waiting on on what white will do here so
white just continues with the move Rook
to E1 the idea of Rook to E1 is maybe we
can free up this Square F1 for some of
our pieces so maybe our H Knight could
go to F1 go to E3 and maybe we could
fully support this F5 Square so we can
have a nice
outpost black plays to move Queen to E7
so just slowly trying to do something as
moving the queen does connect their
Rooks now we have Knight H to F1 so
continuing that idea of trying to
infiltrate Black's position and improve
the placement of their
pieces so we have the move King to h8
played by black so black is a little bit
stuck here as we can tell due to his
lack of space and where his pieces are
placed so the Bishops are really bad
Knights are really bad so black is just
essentially waiting and playing their
King to the corner now white plays
Knight to E3 excellent we are keeping an
eye on this F5
Square so black plays the move Knight E8
so once again black is just dancing
around not much that they can do just
waiting for white to maybe make a move
or just keep their strong
Fortress so now we have the move Pawn to
B6 played by white here so white
carefully found the correct time to
essentially gain space so previously
with the queen on d8 we couldn't really
play any ideas like Pawn to B6 as after
capture capture there might might be
ideas where black could maybe play
Knight A6 to essentially close off the a
file and maybe Target the B6 Pawn so
white just slowly but surely made sure
everything was in the right manner in
order to gain space so B6 gaining a lot
of space just trying to solidify on the
queen side so we have Pawn to A6 so
black refuses to take the pawn on B6
reason being is that it essentially
gives white a lot of play so for example
a takes B6 a takes B6 so now the Rooks
are facing each
other now if black were to capture The
Rook we would simply capture back and we
have full dominance over the a file so
maybe we can jump in with Queen to A7
start attacking this B7 Pawn and in
addition we can bring more pieces into
the game with maybe Rook to A1 creating
a battery so a couple of ideas here and
if black does think of the idea of just
moving their Rook away kind of the same
story we'll play our Rook to
A7 and attack this Pawn maybe create
some batteries and just essentially push
towards the queen side and maybe get
this Pawn down the board to promotion
so that's why black did not take and
plays to move Pawn to A6 so essentially
closing up the position and trying their
best not to give white any chances for
counterplay here so now we have to move
Knight to E5 Knight E to F5 so we're
hopping into this very strong Outpost it
attacks the queen and Bishop at the same
time
and also it's kind of hitting these
backwards pawns so if left unprotected
maybe the White Knight could pounce on
that so black just simply plays the move
Queen F7 just getting out the danger of
the Knight attacking it so now we have
the move Bishop to E2 so since white has
a lot of space they can take the time to
maneuver their pieces and improve the
place B ments of where they are so the
bishop on D3 it's pretty good as it
contributes towards the center but is
kind of blocked off by the C4 and E4
Pawn so with Bishop to E2 tarash is
looking at ways to maybe
infiltrate Black's position and start
creating threats and specifically what
he has in mind is to play this move
Bishop to H5 trying to attack the queen
and maybe if the queen moves away
There's an opportunity for white to
maybe capture the Knight on E8 and take
away this D6 Pawn as this Knight was
protecting
it so we have the move Rook to G8 played
by black here so
essentially giving a little bit of space
for the black queen to go to and
actually matter of fact here if black is
careless the queen could be trapped so
for example if we play a silly move like
Rook B8 we have Bishop to H5 Queen to G8
and we have a very nice move to trap
this queen on G8 by playing Knight to E7
and this queen has absolutely no squares
to go to and sooner or later the queen
will be
captured so hence why black plays to
move Rook to G8 so the position is very
very favorable B for white here so white
just still continues their idea by
playing to move Bishop to H5 attacking
the queen improving their pieces and
black just plays the move Queen to f8
just to run away from the threat and as
you can notice here due to the lack of
space for black all their pieces are
cramped very passive and not many plans
or activities that black can try to do
here so now we have the move Queen to C1
he played here by white so white is
taking their time they have lots of
space they don't have to worry about
anything and now they have ideas of
maybe transferring the queen to A3 maybe
to
F3 or any other ideas maybe try to find
some way to attack these weak pawns
specifically D6 here
so we have the move Rook d8 so black
finally wakes up their Rook on A8 and
goes to d8 but with this Rook on d8 all
these pieces are just coming closer
together all cramped not much that they
can do here so Queen A3 is played by
white and now we have Bishop to see it
so black just dancing around nothing
much that they can do do due to the lack
of space so Bishop to E3 is played by
white so now white is trying to
formulate some sort of plan so he
notices that he's extended a lot over
the queen side not much that could be
done black has a little bit of space on
the king side but all their pieces are
cramped there so don't really want to
try to give black any chances by opening
up the king side and allowing their
pieces is to breathe so what white is
may be thinking here is to try to pursue
an idea of attacking D6 and C5 as if
it's successful we're able to maybe push
these pawns down the board and get some
plan so now black just plays Rook to D7
so just once again due to the lack of
space nothing that they can do here but
just dance around so now we have Rook a
to C1 so essentially preparing for ideas
of once we get these pawns out of the
way just start pushing down the
board so black just plays Rook d8
they're just dancing around nothing that
they can do now we have Rook e D1 so it
is very very evident that there is some
sort of brilliant way to pretty much
explode Black's Fortress here and get
these Pawns rolling down the board so
now we have Bishop to D7 and now here
comes the perfect opportunity for white
to fully exploit Black's position so I'm
going to give you a couple uh a minute
or two just to evaluate this position
what could be done in order to fully
utilize our Rooks and all of our pieces
that are lined up towards the C and D
Pawn so if we take a look at Defenders
the only thing defending the C5 Pawn is
the D6 pawn and we have two attackers on
C5 so we have the queen on A3 and we
have the bishop on C5 so that could be
an idea and for the D6 Pawn there's a
couple of Defenders maybe the Knight
maybe the Queen protecting D6 two
Defenders while we have one attacker
which is our Knight on F5 so for the
most part they're holding everything but
we are ready to destroy the position so
in the chat we have a couple of ideas we
have Bishop takes Knight and Knight
takes D6 so let's take a look at Bishop
takes D6 uh on the Knight on E8 so if
the bishop takes on E8 what black can
maybe do is just capture back with the
bishop so still kind of renewing another
Defender onto the D6 square and now this
bishop has some play to go around maybe
it can go alongside this diagonal maybe
to G6 trying to maybe attack the pawn
maybe support H uh attack the Knight
Excuse Me Maybe support H5 H4 G4 maybe
create some sort of initiative but it
all it is all slow again and actually
here if we capture the excuse me if we
capture the Knight on E8 if anything we
are helping our opponent as this Knight
on E8 is pretty much useless it has no
squares to go to as it's occupied by its
own pieces and of course C7 is guarded
by our B6 Pawn so the right move here
which many of us in chat are saying
which is excellent is to attack the base
Pawn the pawn that is protecting all the
other pawns so this D6 Pawn protecting
C5 and E5 what we can do is take that
pawn on
D6 so we're moving it now black is left
with two options here well they have two
main options they can either capture the
queen back the Knight back with the
queen or with the Knight and of of
course you don't want to let the Knight
get off the hook because next move we're
ready to capture on C5 support the
Knight and maybe this Knight can just
grab a little bit more dinner on B7 then
C5 then A6 so the best thing to do is
capture back on D6 so in the game we
have Knight takes
D6 played here by black so now what
happens if the queen takes on D6 well
after the queen takes on D6 what we can
do here is capture the pawn on C5 as the
D6 Pawn is no longer there and with the
bishop on C5 it is supported by the
queen on A3 and we are attacking this D6
Queen so the queen would have to run
away and its only safe square is to play
Queen to
B8 and
although black
does have an extra piece what black what
white can do is just play Bishop to F7
maybe pick up the imbalance of a rook
for two pieces but then again white
probably wouldn't want to do that just
because of the fact that all their
pieces are passive they don't really
have any squares to go to due to the
lack of space so that's what happens if
the queen were to take but now black
decides to take with the Knight here so
white replies back with Bishop takes C5
so creating a battery with the queen on
A3 and Bishop on C5 and putting pressure
onto this Knight on D6 as there's only
one Defender and we have two attackers
now black plays the move Bishop to C8 so
moving the bishop out the way so this
Rook on d8 can now protect the Knight on
D6 now what B does here is play to move
Bishop to G4 so with the idea of Bishop
to G4 the bishop on H5 has pretty much
already done its job maybe we can trade
it off and that's what white is hoping
for and in addition if we are able to
trade the Bishops off then maybe we have
access to put pressure on the pin piece
so we have this pin alongside the A3 and
f8 diagonal and we could maybe try to
get Knight F5 in and put pressure on
this Knight on D6 overwhelming it and we
couldn't do that earlier before because
if we try that black will just simply
take Pawn takes maybe black gets to Live
Another Day although it is very hard
maybe there's some ideas of Bishop B4 C5
C6 just start running the pawns down the
board
but then again all slow and tiring so
Bishop to G4 offering the trade of
Bishops here and black doesn't really
have much better to do but to trade the
Bishops off so we have H takes G4 so
reclaiming back the bishop and black
just plays Rook D7 just once again
dancing around due to the lack of space
and now and finally we can play Knight
to F5 finalizing our pressure on to this
Knight on D6 as it is pinned we have one
two three attackers on the n and black
has one two Defenders on the night so we
will win that due to our num so there's
nothing much black can do black decides
to just try to get out the pin create
some sort of battery maybe free up some
space for for their pieces maybe the
Knight can go to f8 G6 now and maybe
this Rook can start moving so we just
simply pick up
D6 we pick up the Knight black plays
Knight to f8 now they're trying their
best to come back in the game but
unfortunately since we have pretty much
taken away Black's Fortress what we can
do here is just start advancing so Pawn
to C5 is played by white so we are ready
to essentially get our pawns down the
end of the board and bring some new
Queens into the game so we have C6
coming up maybe trading off the pawns
and just essentially going for the win
so we have Knight to G6 so following up
with the plan but it's kind of too late
now so we have Pawn to C6 so gradually
continuing this idea of gaining space
extending at the right time
and pretty much punishing black for
their lack of space and peace
coordination so B takes C6 pretty much
their best move here we simply capture
back and black decides to capture the
bishop on D6 with their Rook as there
isn't really much safe squares for the
Rook it's only real safe square is maybe
Rook to F7 but there's ideas where we
could probably make a tactic Discovery
sacrifice and maybe attack the queen or
just continue this idea of just marching
the pawns down the board and winning the
game but black a bit desperate just
captures the bishop and the best way to
capture which tardos did correctly is
with the queen so up a lot of material
and whenever you're up material it's
always best to simplify make the game
easy for yourself so white is up the
material due to the fact that there's a
rook for a rook Knight for Knight Queen
for Queen but this imbalance of a rook
for a bishop white is up the exchange so
after Queen takes D6 Rook takes D6 black
throws in the towel as there is nothing
that can be done to stop the B6 and C6
Pawn running down the board and Black's
pieces are all cramped on the king side
and unfortunately there's nothing that
can be done so for example maybe a
sample output maybe playing Knight to F4
trying to maybe get some cheeky fork in
maybe win The Rook but we could still
probably play C7 ignore it because after
Knight E2 King F1 Knight takes C1 we're
just going to play B7 and gaining a
queen is inevitable here so from this
game we saw that tar was able to
successfully take advantage of his
opponent's lack of peace coordination
and his opponent's passiveness and
essentially gain space at the right time
and use that to the full advantage so
very excellent game by tarash and now we
have another game this time where we do
have the space Advantage but a misuse of
that Advantage so
overextending not playing their pieces
onto the right squares and they will be
punished so let's take a look at another
game so this game is between Eugene Tor
and anat karpov and this was in bad
lerberg at FG the Federal Republic of
Germany in
1977 so a couple details about these
players Eugene Tori is a Filipino chess
Grandmaster in 1974 at 22 years old he
became the first Filipino and non-soviet
Asian to qualify for the title of
Grandmaster and toi Kpop he's a Russian
Grandmaster and was the former World
chess champion from
1975 to 85 and he was also Fay world
champion from 1993 to
1999 so let's take a look at this game
so Tor was white and karov was black so
we have Pawn to E4 and pawn to C5 so
once again another sicilan we have
Knight to F3 and this time instead of
Knight H6 karpov continues with kind of
the French variation of the Sicilian and
plays
E6 now white continues to gain space and
plays the move d4 and karpov does follow
the principle of the of the Sicilian is
that whenever white plays D4 always
capture it so capture Knight takes D4
and we have the move Pawn to A6 so
essentially stopping any pieces from
going to this B5 square and now white
plays the move Pawn to C4 so now we have
the structure and this is Ilan called
the maroxy bind so essentially having
this Pawn on C4 and E4 locking up this
D5 Square so essentially a long-term
plan that black wants to do is just
break through explode the center with a
move like Pawn to C5 but with C4 it's
prophylactically stopping any of those
ideas and in addition it does stop
C5 so uh B5 excuse me so we have Queen
to C7 played by
black and we have the move Pawn to A3 so
a bit of bit of a prophylactic move
white would love to play a move like
Knight C3 but there might be some
worries of this bishop coming to B4 so
hence why A3 is played so we have Knight
to F6 so following opening principles
developing your pieces and this Knight
on F6 is now attacking the unprotected
E4 Pawn so white develops and protects
E4 now we have Knight to C6 so
challenging the Knight on D4 we have
Bishop to E3 played by Tor as it pretty
much supports this Knight on D4 so if
you're ready to take me I'll be ready to
take back with my bishop or with my
queen so we have Bishop to E7 the idea
is just simply developing maybe next
move we're ready to Castle here
we have Rook to C1 so essentially making
their Queens side pieces fully to their
potential fully used to their potential
as this Rook lines up with the queen on
C7 so there might be some ideas where
white could maybe try to provoke some
sort of sacrifice on D5 or B5 so black
plays the move Knight to E5 so
essentially kind of releasing the
tension of these Knights attacking each
other and maybe the Knight wants to
transfer over to the king side this time
maybe it's had enough on the queen side
so we have the move Bishop E2 and black
just plays Knight to G6 maneuvering
their Knight to the king side and maybe
putting a
strong uh restriction onto that F4
Square so no immediate F4 Grand Pricks
attacks by white here and also Al we
should keep in mind that this Pawn on C4
is poison we should not take this Pawn
at all because if black captures on C4
we have Bishop takes C4 Queen takes C4
and this nasty move Knight to D5
Discovery attack on this queen and in
addition I am ready to bring my knight
to C7 and Fork your rook and king at the
same time so for example Queen A2 which
is really White's uh excuse me Black's
Queen's only safe Square we're going to
play Knight C7 then we're going to pick
up the Rook on A8 so probably best for
black is to maybe capture the rook and
then pick up the Knight but all is just
really really bad for black so hence why
Knight G6 is played we have castling
played by white so King safety maybe now
we're ready to play F4 we have this Rook
on the f file we have enough Defenders
to go for F4 gaining space so we have
Pawn to B6 so black is just slow and
steady trying to maybe F Shadow their
Bishop to B7 keep an eye on this E4 pawn
and maybe start to just create some
small attacks and threats so we have
Pawn to F4 our we another step of
gaining a lot of space here for white
now we're ready for ideas like E5 F5 Etc
so black just simply
castles and we have the move Pawn to B4
played by white so we are really added
we really want to gain space here for
white so maybe white is ready to play
ideas like Knight B3 maybe support with
C5 just dominate the queen side while we
have space on the king side and center
and there's nothing much black can do as
their pretty laidback so we have Bishop
to B7 fan shadowing the bishop and now
putting pressure on to this E4 Pawn so
two attackers while we only have one
Defender so white has to do something
about that and plays to move Bishop D3
so simultaneously protecting E4 and C4
at the same time now we have Rook a to
C8 so black is just improving the
placement of their pie
Rook A8 is an excellent move as it's
ready to maybe
Counterattack uh White's advancements of
their ideas of C5 sometime in the future
and it also gives black an opportunity
to play Queen B8 so this queen won't
fall into any trouble with this Rook on
C1 and this time the Rooks would be the
ones attacking each other so we have
Knight to B3 played by white so the
ready to go for some ideas of C5
hopefully so black plays the move D6
stopping that idea of C5 so if we were
to play C5 now we would have one two
three Defenders while black would have
one two three four five Defenders so
pretty much stopping Black uh White from
pushing so white decides to play Queen e
to just improve the position connect the
Rooks and essentially create a battery
maybe there still might be ideas of C5
as it would be a discovery attack
attacking this A6 Pawn so we just have
the move Rook F E8 here so maybe some
long-term goals maybe black wants to
play E5 support that sometime in the
future or maybe just have their Knight
come to f8 D7 and just pretty much
reroute so we have the move Pawn to H3
so this idea of H3 a little bit
prophylactic and maybe some ideas of
gaining a lot of space so the king maybe
has a little a little bit extra
breathing room on H2 maybe stopping
ideas of any of Black's pieces coming to
G4 but probably the main reason is to
gain space and play G4 so toret is going
all out here so we have Knight to D7 so
essentially putting more defense on C5
maybe preparing E5 who knows we have
Queen to F2 now so with Queen to F2 we
creating a battery ready to maybe play
F5 ready to maybe pounce on B6 if the
opportunity is given and there's plenty
of ideas that white could go
around and black just Waits a little bit
and plays the move move Bishop to A8 so
essentially waiting for black to make uh
excuse me white to make some sort of
progress and white plays the move Rook
to C2 so white is really fixated on this
idea of playing C5 maybe there's some
ideas where white could just battery up
and essentially continue with their plan
of utilizing their space to the fullest
advantage and addition maybe the queen
could move and this Rook can come to F2
to create a battery so we have Queen to
B8 so removing the queen from the C file
we have Rook fc1 so creating a very
strong battery so probably next move
maybe Knight E2 ready to play C5 Here
and Now black plays this move Bishop to
H4 so with this move Bishop to H4 it's
more of a provoking move kind of just
ticking white off a little bit cuz
they're going to have to move their
Queen again or they're going to have to
play Pawn to G3 which will kind of slow
their space uh idea from planning so G3
is still played by Tor here and uh
carpov just simply goes back to Da so we
have a majority of Black's pieces still
on their very first rank just kind of
waiting for white to do something and
then pouncing for white to make the
wrong move so we have Knight to D2
played here
by white here so maybe some maneuvering
ideas maybe F3 maybe F1 who knows and
just essentially gain putting more
protection on C4 and probably after
sometime hopefully white gets to play C5
they can maybe hop their Knight to C4 so
some future longterm plans here so we
have Bishop to F6 so just essentially
kind of dancing around but then again at
the same time improving the placement of
the bishop so this bishop has some good
control over this long diagonal maybe
ready to take this Knight if need be so
we have to move Pawn to H4 played by té
white and with H4 essentially the goal
is I want to play H5 I want to play G4
G5 H6 I'm going for your king so kpov
anticipates that and just plays the move
H6 not giving white the time to play H5
with a Tempo attacking the knight in
which you would have to move the Knight
and then they're going to play H6
themselves so that's comes to a halt we
have H5 so Tor just continues to push we
have Knight
gf8 so just removing themselves from the
danger of this H5 pawn and we have G4 so
Tor is really coming after the king just
noticing that a bunch of Black's pieces
are kind of on the queen side so maybe
they could use that advantage of their
Bishops their well-placed pieces to just
attack the black king so we have Knight
H7 played by karpu here so essentially
kind of preparing for ideas of G5
stopping that with the enough three
Defenders here while black has excuse me
white has two attackers so essentially
stopping that and Tor really wants to
create action explode the position and
plays to move Pawn to E5 so essentially
cre
creating some sort of initiative
imbalance within the position so
although there's a bunch of pieces
attacking this E5 Pawn one two three
four in fact while white only has one
Defender white is willing to take this
sacrifice in order to maybe open up the
square on e4 for their Knights and also
at the same time activate their Bishop
now a much better approach here with
have actually been the move Queen to G2
now the reason being is that you want to
support this G5 idea so for example a
sample output that could happen would be
B5 C takes B5 and then just a bunch of
exchanges on C3 and white still has this
nice space advantage and ready to create
initiative so with E5 just sacrificing
black has nothing better to do than just
a take you don't really want to play a
move like Bishop E7 otherwise I might
just take on H7 I might just continue
advancing maybe take D6 if need be and
yeah so with E5 we have D takes E5 and
then we have G5
so misusing the space Advantage here by
Tor so this G5 pawn move isn't the best
as there are some good defenses by black
here especially with these pawns Knights
and the Bishops pretty much attacking
them and if anything it kind of helped
black out a little bit as their Bishop
is now activated their Queen will be
activated and their King will most
likely be in danger now so black just
plays e takes uh F4
so if the bishop takes on F4 Bishop E5
would be played which happens in the
game and of course if white captures on
F6 then there's a capture on E3 so
Bishop to Bishop takes F4 Bishop E5 so
blocking the attack of this bishop on F4
to the queen on B8 and now white
continues with the move Pawn to G6 so
just continuing this idea of gaining
space really wanting to attack Black's
King on
G8 and it does come with this idea of
attacking H7 so if black captures on F4
then we can take on H7 which did in fact
happen in the game so F takes G6 H takes
G6 and now Bishop takes F4 we have G
takes H4 so this position has really
really opened up so white has given away
their space Advantage kind of misused it
and now has allowed black to kind of
bounce back in the game we have these
Bishops and these Queens controlling or
pointing towards our uh the white king
and we might fall into trouble pretty
soon here so King h8 just simply Sid
stepping away from the check of course
you don't want to play the king to f8 or
F7 as maybe the pawn will simply promote
or there could be a battery alongside
the file so King to h8 and we have Rook
to F1 so essentially just trying to put
pressure onto this F4 Bishop so we have
two attackers while white has one
Defender so they're going to need to do
something about this bishop on F4 and
carpa finds the best way and plays Rook
to f8 supporting the bishop on F4 and
maybe creating some Tactical ideas here
maybe ready to move this bishop and
Discovery attack on this queen on
F2 so we have Bishop to E4 played by
toret because this bishop on A8 is
really really active and it's nothing
but a nuisance for white as it controls
the G2 and H1 Square for the king so the
best thing to do is just try to trade
off your weak piece for your opponent's
strong piece but unfortunately here this
game ended pretty shortly with Knight to
E5 and after Queen to G2 Knight takes
C4 Tor actually threw in the towel here
as there's just too
much that black has here so although
that they can trade the Bishops the
Queens off and everything there's just
too much material uh too much activity
for black now there's ideas where they
can come to Knight E3 Bishop E3
and so on so maybe a sample output that
could have happened in this game was
Knight takes C4 Rook takes
C4 Queen to E2 Bishop takes E4 Knight
takes E4 the queen captures The Rook
then we capture their Rook on
C2 Knight takes E4 Bishop to E3 check
Queen takes E3 Rook takes F1 King takes
F1 and then Rook takes C2 essentially
just being up the whole exchange and
having a plentiful amount of Pawns and
soon black will just capture the H7 pawn
and there will be some attacks so to
summarize everything we've taken a look
at the theme of space and chess so
essentially the control of squares and
in the first game between tarash and mov
we saw how tar was able to utilize his
space accordingly planned out perfectly
able to take advantage of his opponent's
lack of space and his Integrity of his
pieces and in this game between Tor and
karpov Tor did have a really really nice
space Advantage but did misuse it and
was unable to gain a full advantage and
eventually got counterattacked and lose
the game so that concludes beginner
breakdown my name is National Master
Ralph tan and I thank you for your time
[Music]
okay